speaking of which i i love when we went
to hitler and stalin from
20 30 minutes ago uh gpt 3 generating
doing program synthesis the argument was
about morality of ai versus human
so
um
and specifically in the context of
writing programs specifically in the
context of programs that can be
destructive so running nuclear power
plants or autonomous weapons systems for
example
and i think
your inclination was to say that it's
not so obvious that ai would be less
moral than humans or less effective at
making a a world that would make humans
happy so i i'm not talking about
self-directed systems that are
making their own goals at a global scale
if you just talk about the deployment of
technological systems that are able to
see order and patterns and use this as
control models to act on the goals that
we give them
then if we have the correct incentives
to set the correct incentives for these
systems i'm quite optimistic
but so humans versus ai let me give you
an example
autonomous weapon system
let's say there's a city somewhere in
the middle east that has
a number of terrorists
and the question is what's currently
done with uh with drone technologies you
have information about the location of a
particular terrorist and you have a
targeted attack you have a bombing of
that particular building
and that's all directed by humans at the
high level strategy and also at the
deployment of individual bombs and
missiles like that the actual
everything is done by human except the
the final targeting and the the like the
country so like with spots similar thing
like control the the flight
okay
what if you give ai control in saying
write a program that says
here's the best information i've
available about the location of these
five terrorists
here's the city make sure it's cons all
the bombing you do is constrained to the
city make sure it's precision based
but you take care of it so you do one
level of abstraction out and saying
take care of the terrorists in the city
which are you more comfortable with the
humans
or the javascript gpt3 generated code
that's doing the
the deployment i mean that's this is the
the kind of
question i'm asking is
the kind of bugs that we see in human
nature are they better or worse than the
kind of bugs we see in ai
they're different bugs there is an issue
that if people are
creating an in imperfect automation
of a process that normally requires a
moral judgment
and this mobile judgment is
the reason why it cannot be automated
often is not because the
computation is too expensive
but because the model that you give the
ai is not an adequate model of the
dynamics of the world because the ai
does not understand the context that
it's operating in in the right way and
this is something that already happens
with excel right you don't need to have
an ai system to do this if you have an
automated process in place where humans
decide using automated criteria whom to
kill when
and whom to target when which already
happens
right and you have no way to get off the
kill list once that happens once you
have been targeted according to some
automatic criterion by people right in a
bureaucracy
that that is the issue the issue is it's
not the ai it's the automation
so
there's something about
right it's automation but there's
something about the
there's a certain level of abstraction
where you give control to ai to do the
automation
there's a
scale that can be achieved that it feels
like the scale of bug and scale mistake
and scale of destruction that can be
achieved
of the kind that humans cannot achieve
so ai is much more able to destroy an
entire country accidentally versus
humans it feels like the more
civilians die as they react or suffer as
the consequences of your decisions
the more weight there is on the human
mind to make that decision
and so like it becomes more and more
unlikely to make that decision for
humans for ai it feels like it's harder
to encode that kind of weight
in a way the ai that we're currently
building is automating statistics right
intelligence is the ability to make
models so you can act on them and ai is
the tool to make better models
so in principle if you're using ai
wisely you're able to prevent more harm
and i think that the main issue is is
not on the side of the ai it's on the
side of the human command hierarchy that
is using technology irresponsibly so the
question is how hard is it uh to encode
to to pro to properly encode the right
incentives into the ai so
for instance there's this idea what
happens if we let our airplanes be flown
with ai systems and the neural network
is a black box and so on and it turns
out our neural networks are actually not
black boxes anymore there are
function approximators using linear
algebra and there are performing things
that we can understand
but we can also uh instead of letting
the neural network fly the airplane use
the neural network to generate approval
of the correct program with the degree
of accuracy of the proof that a human
could not achieve
right so we can use our ai by combining
different technologies to build systems
that are much more reliable than the
systems that a human being could create
and so in in this sense i would say that
if you use an early stage of technology
to save labor and don't employ employ
competent people but just to hack
something together because you can that
is very dangerous and if people are
acting under these incentives that they
get away with delivering shoddy work
more cheaply using ai with less human
oversight than before that's very
dangerous the thing is though ai is
still going to be unreliable perhaps
less so than humans but it'll be
unreliable in novel ways
and uh
yeah but this is an empirical question
and it's something that we can figure
out and work with so the issue is do we
trust the systems the social systems
that we have in place and the social
systems that we can build and maintain
that they're able to use ai responsibly
if they can then ai is good news if they
cannot then it's going to make the
existing problems worse
well and also who creates the ai who
controls it who makes money from it
because it's ultimately humans
and then you start talking about how
much you trust the humans so the
question is what does who mean i don't
think that we have identity per se i
think that the story of a human being is
somewhat random
what happens is more or less that
everybody is acting on their local
incentives but they're perceived to be
their incentives and the question is
what are the incentives that the one
that is
pressing the button is operating under
you